bridgewater associates the world's
largest hedge fund is going all in on
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they now
have finally capitulated and they are
helping to fund an external crypto focus
fund this is a huge huge deal now before
we get into what they're actually doing
first let's take a look at bridgewater
themselves bridgewater was founded in
1975 by harvard business school graduate
ray dalio in a manhattan apartment they
now have over 200 billion dollars in
assets under management and they are
officially the world's largest global
hedge fund they're not the only hedge
fund though that has been getting into
the crypto game breven howard also
launched the cryptocurrency hedge fund
back in january and the venture capital
arm of steve cohen's .72 led a 21
million series a funding round in crypto
market intelligence company massari in
2021 and now remember ray dalio who has
studied all the debt cycles who's been
talking about cash's trash for years now
he previously was actually anti-bitcoin
anti-crypto currencies but now that is
all changing rey is famous for saying
the following the one thing i would say
to investors is don't judge anything in
your returns or your assets in nominal
terms in terms of how many dollars you
have
view it in terms of inflation adjusted
dollars well that happens to be a really
important point when the official cpi
measurement is coming in at nearly eight
percent right now now ray also has come
out and said that he now owns bitcoin
ethereum and is into these
cryptocurrencies he's got this quote
where he said bitcoin is one hell of an
invention and boy do i agree with rey
now what we're watching is that the
world is waking up every single
billionaire every single hedge fund on
wall street they're all capitulating
they're all realizing bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are the future these
technologies are not going away there's
over 100 million people who have adopted
them and they simply are superior to the
legacy financial system and products
ultimately having bridgewater jump in
the game is just another milestone it's
another data point that proves this
industry is real this industry isn't
going anywhere and now that the world's
largest hedge fund is in expect many
more to follow hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time